beware the Briny deep because the Meg 2
is bringing back your favorite
megalodons and more to below this
Summer's movie competition out of the
water here's what you need to know about
the action-packed sequel
the original big budget giant megalodon
movie The Meg spent well over a decade
in limbo The Source novel was published
in 1997 but production on the film
version took a while to get going with
the project jumping from Studio to
Studio before things finally ramped up
the Meg landed at Warner Brothers in
2015 and the final choice for John
turtletaba's director came in March 2016
after Eli Roth of hostile bowed out due
to creative differences two years and
four months later in August 2018 the Meg
finally hit Cedars
Megalodon the Meg II the trench also
took its time swimming into movie
theaters around the world however the
wait for the sequel won't be as long as
the one for its predecessor filming got
underway at leavesden studios near
London home of the Harry Potter movies
just over a month later Warner Brothers
confirmed that Meg 2 would arrive in
theaters on August 4th 2023
in a September 2018 newsletter author
Steve Alton expressed his hope that the
Cinematic follow-up to the Meg would be
based on the second novel in his book
series the trench one of the reasons the
sequels to Jaws failed to live up to the
original Alton wrote was that Peter
benchley only wrote the one Jaws novel
the fact that the sequel to The Meg will
be titled the Meg II the trench pretty
strongly implies the screenwriters
agreed with him and it would seem that
the Meg II the trench will adhere to the
plot of Alton's Source novel at least
Loosely judging from the first official
trailer for the film this will be the
kind of sequel that does what its
predecessor movie did only bigger and in
a more extreme fashion a few years after
Jonas Taylor and a squad quelled the
Menace of a Megalodon the team is called
back to duty to fight off an even larger
more frightening and even hungrier apex
predator nothing is safe from this new
Meg so Jonas and James Mac mccreadies
assemble a group of hunters and
researchers to investigate the deep
ocean trench from Once the underwater
Menace came
action movie Powerhouse Jason Statham
will reprise his role as shark hunting
rescue diver Jonas Taylor Cliff Curtis
shuya Sophia Kai and Paige Kennedy will
also be back once more portraying Mac
mccready's May Ying and DJ respectively
new additions to the cast include Sienna
Guillory as the leader of a scientific
contingent Schuyler Samuels as a new
member of Taylor's crew who enjoys a
good adventure and Jing woo star of
Chinese Blockbuster franchise is the
wandering Earth and wolf warrior in an
undisclosed role it's no small
undertaking to remake a film made by the
legendary Alfred Hitchcock particularly
one that won the Academy Award for best
picture but UK based director Ben
Wheatley was willing to take up the task
helming Netflix's 2020 version of the
1940 mystery drama Rebecca just after
that film made a splash Wheatley
accepted an offer to move from intimate
period pieces into big budget action
Blockbusters and signed on to direct Meg
2. it will be the filmmaker's most high
profile project to date coming on the
heels of in the earth Happy New Year
Colin burstead and free fire Wheatley
directed the film from a script written
by the same Trio of writers behind the
first film so it's safe to say that the
sequel will have a similar vibe I just
hope it goes better than last time
have a last time
you don't want to know
nearly five years have passed since the
Megs swam its way into theaters while
many sequels have taken much longer to
produce there are a few pressing
questions regarding how a second film
can work within the ongoing storyline
established in the first film most
pertinently how is there another
Megalodon swimming through the ocean
shockingly the Meg did not kill one
shark by the end of the film two of the
Prehistoric Beasts are slain and while a
third Megalodon seems unreasonable the
second shark creates an opportunity for
more sharks to appear it's near the
beginning of the movie when Winston
chao's character minway Zhang begins his
exploration of the Mariana Trench which
arguably releases the original Megalodon
from an underground Cavern the later
arrival of the second shark insinuates
it even more underwater monsters were
released moreover the second shark is
significantly larger than its
predecessor and fans can bet that the
star sea creature of the sequel will be
even larger finally in the first movie's
final moments another Megalodon can be
heard swimming past the camera
foreshadowing that Jonas Taylor has more
monsters to fight
the announced PG-13 rating may be
unsatisfying for fans hoping for more
blood and violence out of their favorite
shark movie but the family-friendly
rating may be even more disappointing
for franchise star Jason Statham ahead
of the release of the Megan 2018 the
action Superstar discussed some of the
major script changes and directorial
visions of the film with collider
surprisingly Statham had a much
different idea of where the shark movie
should have gone John turtletob's
interpretation of this is a fun end of
Summer movie it's full of humor it's a
little bit more directed to a different
taste of what my own is in terms of I
like more gory adult stuff that said the
actor was quick to admit that he trusted
his director I can't speak for what this
film could possibly speak to a younger
audience I might have made a film that
not many people wanted to see I'm not a
filmmaker unfortunately it seems as if
Statham did not get his wish for a more
adult film with the sequel either
while the Meg primarily takes place on
the ocean the filmmakers needed to find
the right Open Water to film in the
original movie was primarily filmed in
New Zealand a country well known for its
eye-catching scenery director John
turtletop said to the New Zealand film
commission about the location you can
get beautiful Still Water you can get
rough water you can get all the
different kinds of things you need you
can see every kind of ocean it's a
perfect place to go film despite the
love the Meg cast and crew seemed to
have for New Zealand they decided to
change things up for the sequel the Meg
II the trench began filming in the
United Kingdom in early 2022 at the
Warner Brothers Studio in leaveston
however the new shark movie still needed
stunning ocean locations and beautiful
beaches for many of its exterior shots
which led the crew to Thailand the film
crew managed to find an ideal beach in
the Phuket province of Thailand where
the filming took place in Spring 2022
there is no denying that the Meg is a
ridiculous and over-the-top shark movie
but that's part of its charm thankfully
those looking for over-the-top Thrills
are in luck as if the source material is
any clue as to what will happen things
will likely get crazier in the sequel
the trench written by Steve Alton
published in 1999 features Jason
Statham's character Jonas Taylor caring
for a surviving Megalodon who has become
a tourist attraction for people hoping
to catch a glimpse of a massive dinosaur
however when the Beast begins to act
erratically and Escape its cage Jonas
discovers that she is pregnant to catch
the bloodthirsty shark once more he must
set up a trap where he first met the
prehistoric monsters back in the Mariana
Trench
this is a bad idea just a little bit the
book synopsis seems relatively
straightforward but there is far more to
the story than meets the eye including
the arrival of a pack of chronosauruses
a government conspiracy and baby sharks
it sounds like a lot to pack into a
single movie so chances are the film
won't follow it beat for beat but if
there are more Meg films to come we can
expect the adventures to get bigger and
more outrageous with more prehistoric
Monsters climbing out of the depths
the official first trailer for The Meg
II the trench offers some Clues as to
what to expect from the film with
Statham and Company visiting the Mariana
Trench where an entire ecosystem lives
underwater there are many creatures that
begin swimming their way up from the
deepest part of the ocean some of these
creatures are seen throughout the
trailer including human-sized reptiles
and most notably a Tyrannosaurus Rex
however the trailer hints at another
deep sea creature in a blink and you'll
miss it moment thankfully a new
international trailer has surfaced that
features the most dangerous underwater
monster of them all the Kraken the
legendary squid monster rumored to be as
large as the Megalodon the original the
Meg movie also features a giant squid
but that's nothing compared to this new
tentacled Beast surprisingly the new
trailer indicates that the Kraken may be
a more significant villain than the
giant shark and the movie could climax
with the two massive monsters squaring
off for a final battle
there is no shortage of shark movies out
there but most of them have one thing in
common they have a ton of sequels from
Jaws to Sharknado movies about the most
dangerous animal in the ocean tend to be
squeezed for everything they are worth
meanwhile Steve Alton's original
literary Meg Saga includes seven titles
giving the movies plenty to work with so
there is a strong chance that the Meg
may be returning for another swim if
there is a hunger from the audience when
the first movie was released in 2018
there were already talks of a potential
franchise in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Jason Statham was
quick to point out the deciding factor
of the Meg moving forward I think it's
like anything in this day and age if it
makes money there's obviously an
appetite to make more money and if it
doesn't do well they'll soon sweep it
under the carpet but that's the way
Hollywood Works everyone tries to make a
good film and it lies in the hands of
the audience safe to say if the sequel
manages to make a boatload of money
there is no doubt that Warner Brothers
will be ready to complete the trilogy
build a franchise or even expand into a
Cinematic Universe
foreign